welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul in this video we're
breaking down
richer season 2 has just dropped its
finale and episode 8 has a lot to impact
from it trout this video we're going to
be going through what happens and also
talking about where things could be
heading for season 3 that's currently in
production and reach has been a big show
for Amazon therefore there's a lot of
things to go over and in this video
we're going to be breaking down it all
firstly though just a quick word from
our sponsors and then we'll dive into
the season this video is sponsored by Z
biotics now whenever I do a brand deal
or a sponsorship ad like this what'll
happen is that the company will send me
out the product I'll get to try it and
make sure that I truly believe in it out
in my first advert for Z biotics last
year I went through all the stuff used
it myself saw how much of a difference
it made and was more than happy to
advertise it and after that we didn't
agree on doing another Advent or
anything but I was so blown away by how
good this was I actually went out and
bought bought myself a mega packet of it
out of my own money now I'm not as young
as I used to be and the choice is either
to have that great night out or that
great next day that was until I found
zbiotics which is a complete Game
Changer zbiotics pre- alcohol probiotic
drink is the world's first genetically
engineered probiotic it was invented by
PhD scientists to help you feel better
the morning after drinking now here's
how it works when you drink alcohol it
gets converted into a toxic byproduct
right in your gut it's this byproduct
not dehydration that's responsible for
you feeling rough the very next day what
zbiotics does is that it produces an
enzyme that helps break this byproduct
down just remember to make zbiotics your
first drink of the night drink
responsively and the next day you'll
feel great you can see I've already been
using these and every time I drink one
I'm completely Amazed by how I feel the
next day just feel normal whereas
normally I'd feel sick and yeah I can't
imagine going on a night out now without
drinking one of these first go to
zbiotics
docomo or scan the QR code on screen
right now to get 15% off your very first
order you can also sign up to their
subscription service using my code so it
means you're prepared no matter what's
going to happen zbiotics has also got a
100% money back guarantee so if for any
reason you feel unsatisfied they'll give
you your money back no questions asked
remember to head to zbiotics tocom
heavys spoilers and use the code heavy
spoilers at check out for 15% off your
first order thank you again to zbiotics
for changing my life not even being
hyperbolic there really made a
difference and yeah to go check them out
at the link below thanks okay so season
one was primarily about firmly with
Reacher setting out to Avengers brother
Joe season two switches the focus to his
team with the stakes changing to those
in his unit still though that theme of
family comes across with Reacher finding
one in the team that love him you refer
to the special investigators as your
team you know we're more than that
right where things are going to go we'll
discuss in just a bit but firstly I want
to talk about the main things in season
two opening up we see one of his unit
being dropped out of Chopper which comes
full circle in that finale after
learning that they're being picked off
Reacher puts the band back together and
throughout the season he tries to get to
the bottom of it this season being
joined Once More by Neagle and also
David O'Donnell last SE his long lost
love caller Dixon who Reacher used to
want to give a Reacher round
two you learn is they try and find out
who was behind the deaths but also learn
a bigger conspiracies at foot this is
headed up by Robert Patrick langang
strum and an international arms broker
simply known as am Patrick is a great
little addition and they even do a
cheeky Terminator Easter egg during
episode one the ID NE is checking in
under the name Sarah Connor and uh
however where I draw the line it's
having one of the bad guys as a British
comicbook
collector and it it became personal With
Me 0 out of 10 no stars on Trip Adviser
Rotten Tomatoes do not
recommend now but this takes things to a
higher place place in season 1 with it
jumping up to a laric conspiracy now the
season itself based on bad luck and
trouble with a story explaining in a bit
more detail about what's going on we
learn the company uh have managed to
build missiles that are incapable of
missing their targets pretending to get
rid of them they've secretly been
planning to broker a deal with
terrorists through using am am will then
give these terrorists a technology and
they'll be able to carry out their own
attacks AED by police we also meet
detective Russo who's played by Dominic
lomazzi when he's not getting smashed
like the like button by his son Kingpin
he's being a hero cop who gets killed in
the line of duty it's a moments like
this that really Elevate the series as
well as the distrust Reacher feels that
one of his owners betrayed him episode
seven ends with us seeing Reacher go to
langstrom and that takes us into the
finale now we begin with Reacher tied up
to a chair being interrogated by
Langston in order to find e location
being Langston's last loose end means he
has to find her but she's a lot closer
than he thinks upright raing as a sniper
she slowly takes down the guards and
infiltrates the compound along with the
Senator's assassins meanwhile inside
Langston reveals why Swan's been framed
in finger throughout the whole season
not a pun I swear and all Langston's
wanted to do is get richon and I don't
mean the actor that plays richer which
is a pun [__] off Al langson apparently
offered to cut swan in on the deal but
after he refused they used him in other
ways placing his eyes and fingers in a
jaw this has given them access to
everything inside realizing that reach
won't talk he decides to go and pick up
's father who who in the end gets a
visit from someone else escaping using
one of those safety pining you know you
know the one you used to stick them in
your shoe at school as well and
Richard's done that too and we see as he
uses it to pick the handcuffs free while
this is going on number one Grandpa
Neagle in the Senus assassins storm the
base which leads to Reacher getting to
the chopper just like the book we see
his Reacher ends up pushing Langston out
the back to kill him the same way that
he killed his company in an
investigation assumptions
kill
Hey cuz he cuz he kept saying that and
we then have a moment with Langston on
the ground where we zoom in on his face
which brings things full circle from the
opening of episode one he somewhat
redeems the team's death by also saving
Cara after her bed dangles outside the
chopper where things differ from the
book is that when richer landed he ended
up asking the pilot if he flew during
the times his teammates got murdered
revealing that he did he then shut him
in the cockpit whereas here they play
things a bit more theatrical he lets him
think that he's escaped and then shoot
stand the chopper using a little wing
rocket on board was also a weapon
engineer that was the only one capable
of showing the terrorists how to use the
chips this is a big change up from the
book as in that they ended up letting
him live they found out that his
daughter was being held hostage and he
was pretty much being forced to teach
the terrorists I think the whole
daughter thing though that that's been
done twice already in the show so they
just kept things simple and had them go
down in flames speaking of going down in
flames am's also killed and the Senators
arrested along with his guns for hire
now in the book Reacher then used the
money to set up trust funds for the
unit's family and also gave a donation
to Peter in the name of Swan's dog that
then had him getting a deposit in his
bank which was used as the code AS say
mission accomplished I was surprised
they didn't do this as that deposit
tipped him off in episode one and they
also skip over another deposit as well
in the book there was a separate amount
dropped in of
the book ended much like the show with
Reacher heading out on a bus without any
plans like you on a Saturday night hey
you loser you [__] loser now in the
show we watch Reacher put on Beat the
Machine by Quaker City Nighthawks this
song Is Well about beating the machine
and it carries a lot of meaning for
these final few scenes throughout the
season there's been a constant back and
forth of a song Choice with that
signaling how the group felt Talking
Heads R nowhere was called the Feist
with a song pyo K being brought up as
well last week was the mang go through
and this one had Neely playing Jefferson
airplanes White Rabbit White Rabbit was
created because the band thought it was
funny that the story's parents used to
read their kids eventually led to them
being visions that they saw on
psychedelic drug trips whether that's
why negly picked it for the kids I don't
know but either way those were the main
ones that had other meanings Peter
machine sees the families getting money
along with the detective's brother
getting a lumsum for the kids instead of
Peter getting in the book we see a local
animal Sheltering Macy's name and nly's
father getting around the clock medical
team to help with his illness this is
him covered for the rest of his life and
we see as a group shareff final drink
around the campfire Reacher reveals he's
given some to negly and though he hasn't
given it all to David he's deposited
some into his kids accounts he's also
starred in LLC for Cara so she can
finally work for herself taking a
picture this builds off the back of the
one from earlier in the season in which
the group all posed around the campfire
and took one as well though their
members of dwindle the team's still
strong and richer and Cara have some
special time together he was going to
use his money to buy a toothbrush but
caller's got him one now so he can use
it for something else sure as [__] won't
be for an engagement ring though and
though it's clear caller on to be with
him he heads out on the road biddly we
hear the song Simple Man Ming his skin a
and see as he heads out after doing what
he's considered visiting family where
he's going to go we don't know we don't
know Pro but he's probably going to go
to his American Idol audition you are
the sunshine of my
lifeo that's why always stay
round you are the apple of my eye oh
forever you stay
in now as for where things can go in the
future there are a couple of bits of
info that we already know the first
season was based off the first book but
season 2 took a slight unexpected turn
with bad luck in trouble that's the 11th
entry in the Jack Reacher Cannon so I
wasn't thinking we could just go up
through releases to make things even
more difficult richson remain tight
lipped and as said he won't say what
it's going to be however he has stated
it's his favorite Reacher book and thus
we can look at the most popular entries
the one that normally tends to hit the
top spot is one shot which may colliders
number one however that was already
adapted into the Tom Cruz film and thus
I don't think that they're going to hit
that route there's also that follow-up
never go back which is another that I
think they're probably going to skip
doing my research diving deep into all
the interviews that the actors had I
actually managed to track down what he
said to his favorite book in an
interview with slashfilm Rich and said
he Love Die Trying and that that richer
book was the one he wanted to do the
most that was also the second to release
so doing that for season 3 makes a bit
of sense initially set in Chicago it has
Reacher going cross country to track
down an FBI agent who was abducted at
gunpoint I don't want to spoil what the
twists in the story are but I think it
would be a good plot for the show the
Agents called Holly and her co-workers
joining the search which could add to
the Ensemble aesthetic that the show
always carries it also features a group
of army radicals that we learn have
moved to the mountains and made a
community they want to distance
themselves from the US and it adds an
interesting angle they could add into
the show richer of course leads his own
unit and these guys could act as a dark
miror to show what he could become on
one side you've got the FBI and on the
other this military group Reacher is
going to kind of work down the middle
and go his own route in order to get
Justice such a cool way I think they
could go and yet that might be suming
that they end up doing next time and
bear in mind we got Early Access to
these episodes so if the finale's
dropped and they've come out said that
it's all wrong then drop it in the
comments and call me an idiot I'd
appreciate that I'd appreciate you call
me that and answer my thoughts on the
season I'm happy to say that I enjoyed
the show and I felt it delivered on what
I was expecting as with the first entry
the plot's pretty basic but it's some
comes in and gets the job done they do a
good job of keeping the twists coming
from time to time and pacing wise
they're pretty much nailing it you jump
between action and drama moments
perfectly with each episode managing to
balance both I feel like Amazon had
really crafted a hit here that's going
to become the boys but for dads adapting
boys is for dads but you know what I
mean but adapting richer into a show it
seems like an outb brainer now but yet
it works with what it sets out to do I
have to admit I was a bit of a latecomer
and only start the season back in
November still though I've enjoyed the
ride and love the sort of self-contained
nature that each season has if I had to
compare it to another show I'd probably
say The Incredible Hulk and not cuz
Rich's built like L Forno that had him
kind of rolling into town sorting
problems out and being on his way reach
is a Drifter who helps where he can but
you know that he's not someone who's
going to stick around each season each
season's kind of like an Incredible Hulk
episode stretched out like those jeans
over a whole season butchering this
metaphor but I love the Simplicity and
almost nostalgic feeling I have watching
the show it feels like a throwback to a
classic procedural that works as a
guilty pleasure but also something that
you can just sit back and enjoy Also I
love how everyone calls richer richer
and even his who have the surname richer
they still call him richer that's how
you know he's richer number one and at
the core of it you're kind of hoping
that he gets to find a home but know
that this man's life is meant for the
road it's got action comedy drama and
also a slight slight sadness to it makes
it all around a really strong watch I
know forb said that it felt like season
one dumbed down but me to me it's the
same sort of show I can't get the
criticism though and it probably doesn't
do enough on top of what it did to
really feel like a step up but hey I
feel like I'd be nitpicking saying that
cuz they definitely delivered on what my
expectations were so yeah I recommend
reer if for whatever reason you're
watching this without seeing it bit
weird of you mate uh but I'm kind of
annoyed at myself for missing the bot on
weekly breakdowns but hopefully for
season 3 we can try and work something
out please drop a like on the video if
you want to see those and if you want to
support the channel as a member of the
spoiler Society then please click the
join button you'll get early access to
videos every week and it goes such a
long way to helping us out going to get
some heavy spoilers merch we've also got
a t-shirt line loc below the video video
that will let you pick up all kinds of
tops like our Theory time on House of
dragon stuff Marvel te's and more we
drop new designs on there all the time
too so definitely keep an eye out and
huge thank you for all your support have
you want some else to watch we've got a
breakdown on screen right now and
hopefully I see you over there right
after this by the way huge thank you for
sticking through this I've been Paul
I'll see you next time take care
[Music]
peace
oh